ELENA ALBERTI: In
thinking about what
was the most impactful
takeaway from this course,
I really realized that the
most important part for me
was the self-reflection,
and kind of delving
into what I thought my
racial identity was,
as I am multiracial.
So I just kind of identify
with different things
at different times, and
seeing how that actually
fits my personality and
what that means for myself.
What about you guys?
DANA VIGUE: Yeah,
going off of that,
as another multiracial
person, I started
to realize as we engaged with
the social scientific theory
behind the way
people code-switch,
that there is a
science behind it.
And it's not arbitrary.
It's not chaotic.
It's part of a
larger social system
with institutionalized
expectations for the way people
engage with one another and
other institutions in place.
And understanding
that we're sort
of following by an unspoken
set, and occasionally very
vehemently spoken
set of rules, when
we do that-- when we
identify differently
in different circumstances--
was something I hadn't actually
explicitly realized.
ELENA ALBERTI: Mhm.
LORRAINE WONG: I agree
that the self-exploration
and the self-reflection was
the most important takeaway,
I think, that I could get
personally from the course,
in addition to all the
academic readings that we did--
all of the engagement with
the outside world that we did.
I think, in order to be
able to change the world,
first we have to
understand ourselves.
And it helped me do all of
that, and navigate the tensions
between how I am
read and how I am,
and trying to figure
out those differences.
COLIN GODWIN: I think
what I most enjoyed
about the class was, outside
of the self-awareness,
increasingly reading
into the patterns
that we see in
society, and how that
influences how we see others.
A really impactful
part was when we
delved into why creole and
other developing languages
are considered to
be lesser languages.
And how there wasn't really
much science behind that.
It was more just
cultural leading
of whites being
superior to blacks
and the preservation of
slavery through another form--
through both the disparagement
of Creole and African-American
English.
ELENA ALBERTI: Bouncing
off that as well, I
think another
important part was,
I mentioned before,
the multiracial aspect.
But in class, Dana.
You were talking about how one
of the more ant parts was also
talking about how historically
under-represented groups or--
I forgot the exact
terminology you used--
can form alliances.
And how there are similarities,
but also dissimilarities
between how the groups work.
And I think classes
like these allow
you to discuss people in general
who are in those situations,
but also allows you delve
into the nitty-gritty
like you're talking
about with Creole.
DANA VIGUE: Yeah,
I was surprised
how much a class
entitled Black Matters
dealt with things that
you would never identify
as a specifically black issue.
And we ended up talking about
populations that are not read,
or may not identify, as black.
And that was relevant.
These were not tangentially
related political issues
or social issues or
economic injustices.
And I started to see how
black issues and black matters
and black experiences are
really not something that
can be studied in
isolation, and play
into larger global networks.
ELENA ALBERTI: Mhm.
COLIN GODWIN: Yeah, because
a lot of themes in the course
were centered around the
mechanisms of oppression
instead of what the oppression
of a particular group.
So it was really nice
having those case studies
inside of immigrant populations
and American populations
as well.